alt und alle mal die fresse jetzt rede
ich überfragt die kastration 20
millionen kastrierte deutsche fackel pro
jahr
das heißt alle zwei sekunden wird bei
uns ein ferkel ohne betäubung enteilt
und das darf so weitergehen dank union
und spd bleibt deutschland für
schweinezüchter ein echtes bälle
paradies dabei hatten die
schweinezüchter fünf jahre zeigt auf
narkose umzustellen wurde absichtlich
verband wir reden hier von lebewesen
verdammt noch mal wenn ich ein ferkel
völlig ohne narkose kastrieren verspürt
ist ganz deutlich schmerz das wissen wir
heute sehr genau das ist
wissenschaftlich evaluiert echt mit
einer zange die eier abreißen blut wie
gut dass das mal jemand wissenschaftlich
evaluiert hat steht doch schon in der
bibel
du sollst nicht töten und warum die
ganze quälerei weil etwa zehn prozent
der eba einen zitat strengen geruch
entwickeln was ist denn das für ein
scheiß begründung 100 prozent der
männlichen teenager haben auch einen
strengen geruch preisen wir gehen doch
auch die euro
bestimmt besser in der schule kastration
mit narkose kostet pro tier 2 bis 5 euro
na und dann zahl ich eben als
verbraucher am ende ein paar cent mehr
für mein nackensteak in einer marinade
wieder sollten uns echt alle schämen und
zwar in grund und boden
deutschland ist der drittgrößte schweine
produzent der welt nach china und den
usa
bei uns ist schweinefleisch in allen
blättern tofu cherry hey da habe ich
eine idee
stellen wir uns doch mal der realität
los wecken sie ihre kinder ein
schweinchen namens babe teil 3 jetzt
geht's an die nüsse es ist ein kurzer
schnitt der hoch umstritten ist
bis zum siebten lebenstag dürfen
schweine in deutschland ohne narkose
kastriert werden wie habt ihr gut
aufgepasst so klingt die wurst mit
gesicht bevor sie auf eurem shoot landet
jedes mal wenn sich diese kokon aus
irgendetwas einigt wird nur schlimmer
ach da fällt mir ein rätsel ein
was haben deutsche fackeln und die spd
gemeinsam keine eier
[Applaus]
[Musik]